This job...
We try to save as many people as we can
Sometimes that doesn't mean everybody
But you don't give up
New York
Washington D.C
Sokovia
Ok... That's enough
Captain
People are affraid
That's why I'm here
we need to be put in check
What ever form that takes I'm game
I'm sorry Tony
If I see a situation pointed south I can't ignore it
Sometimes I wish I could
Sometimes I want to punch you in your perfect teeth
I know we are not perfect
But the safest hands are still our own
Rhodes!
I was wrong about you
The whole world was wrong about you
There coming for you
I'm not the one who needs to watch their back
This doesn't have to end in a fight Tony
You just started a war
Stay down final warning
I could do this all day
Alright I've run out of patients
Underoos
Hey everyone